if we follow the dc timeline then what i
think is supposed to happen is elon musk
will send a crew to mars who will
accidentally uncover
an ancient temple where a bunch of
invasive aliens were frozen by the
martians
who will then be awoken by the astronaut
take over his body or take assume his
form come to earth and there would be a
secret invasion
and you know the justice league there's
a well-known theory that
um i mean facts are not endorsements
but there's a well-known theory that
there was some kind of nuclear
war between earth and mars which used to
be colonized because of what
yeah because of what it's established
it's an established theory you can look
it up
so yeah so it's that there was some sort
of um
nuclear war some sort of war between
earth and mars which we used to be like
heavily colonized and that's why mars
looks the way it does what did you read
when did you hear about this oh when did
i hear about that um
i i think i was in a youtube rabbit hole
at three in the morning
a long time ago no because this is from
newsweek march 22nd
viral mars conspiracy theory video
claims humans lived on mars and
destroyed it
there it is youtube rabbit holes yeah so
you can go ahead and read that that is
that was interesting a video in which a
tick tock user claims humans once lived
on mars but rendered it uninhabitable in
a nuclear war has gone viral
thanks to newsweek the news that's fit
the false but entertain the false thanks
for letting me know it's false oh cool
yeah that entertaining theory also
states this war
would have caused a nuclear winter which
is responsible for mars popular red
color
iron what i don't think it has currently
been liked more than 230 000 times and
shared nearly 10 000 times it's not even
that many shares
yeah i know i did nothing i didn't like
it or share it i just read it
i think that it has been watched 979
thousand times
that was from our video with alex jones
has doubled the views on that
this is not this is someone was bored
they were
this is the stuff that that comes up
when everybody else is shadow band
i wonder if people used to live on venus
you guys ever think about wait wait wait
i'm sorry i gotta read this
the theory explained by user crackhead
joe dirt
so you know it's it's oh my gosh it's
verified was put forward in response to
the question what's a conspiracy theory
that
absolutely blows your mind crack
crackhead joe dirt states
mars isn't naturally red want to know
what can cause a planet turn red and
change after a couple million years
if enough nukes were to go off on a
planet the first thing that would happen
is a nuclear winter
nuclear winter is the aftermath of
nuclear blasts causing ash that is so
thick
it blocks out the sun nuclear winters
can last anywhere from 100 years
and a thousand depending on how much ash
in the atmosphere
after all the natural resources are
drained up from the nuclear winter the
planet turns red from dust
my theory is that we've come from mars
after we drained all its natural
resources and destroyed it with nuclear
bombs
that is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard the red color is iron
you can like that was very weirdly
worded
yeah but after the resources are drained
up what is that what does that mean
by that venus makes way more sense not
mars
for sure because the sun's expanding
slowly so it used to not be so
hot on venus well no venus is hot
because of a greenhouse effect
they had they thought there were all
these cometary impacts on venus it turns
out they're like
explosives from the inside like it
cooked so hot that it
blew out all this goo outside of itself
and there's all these like explosive
holes where it's inside
hold on you know let me tell you a
better conspiracy theory all right mars
makes no sense because mars is too small
it has no magnetosphere as my
understanding so it can't maintain an
atmosphere
so the solar radiation just rips away
the particles and blasts them off the
planet
so we can't terraform it if we wanted to
it's the oceans that caused the field
unless i guess no it's the iron partly
ocean contributes a lot to it so i guess
what we would need to do is like drill
to the center of mars and then
get like ben affleck in the in the gang
to launch those nukes in sequential
order like in that movie okay
armageddon i'll tell you what's better
this is sad okay
look i'm sorry crackhead joe dirt i
appreciate your attempt but let me let
me school you for a second
humans started on venus and venus was
earth-like
but a runaway greenhouse effect from
mass consumption and carbon emissions
resulted in the in global warming which
crate and the pollution started creating
acid rain the ocean levels started
rising and then once
the american military american but once
the venetian venusian whatever
venus military of one country realized
what was happening they created the ark
project
where they took the dna samples from as
many animals and species as possible and
put it onto a giant space vessel called
the ark
that would ferry as many people as
possible and many animals and creatures
to earth to get here because venus was
being destroyed so they flee and then
the ark project comes and the great
flood
sweeps over venus wiping out all
civilization from global warming and
then they land on earth
and then what do we see in the fossil
record the pre-pre-cambrian explosion
all of a sudden around the same time the
fossil record just boom tons of
different animals why
because the ark project dropped a bunch
of the the critters
and then they started populating and
then all started dying around the same
time so now they appeal
here in the fossil record as this great
unexplainable elite i don't actually
believe that but come on let's be real
it's a way better conspiracy theory than
mine it might explain octopuses we don't
know
dude they look like the brain and stem
creature inside
their bodies and there's like weird dna
stuff and there's just
they don't make sense for earth looks
like a
jungle planet that got superheated it
really looks like it used to be a jungle
planet we landed a drone there and it
got
i think the russians did it got crushed
and just like melted or something
yeah i was i was watching this video
where they claimed that we could make
floating cities on venus because the
gases are so
dense that we could make like floating
platforms on gas just heated by like the
geothermal
heat from underneath i think it's just a
hot planet wow that's a lot of energy
potential to boil water
yeah well you know where on earth we'd
go to mars but mars can't sustain an
atmosphere as my understanding so
what do we do we're just trapped on
earth you all know it's really scary you
want to know the scariest thing
the universe is expanding right uh-huh
so eventually
on earth once the universe expands to a
certain point
you won't actually be able to see any
stars or planets or galaxies or anything
because they'll be so far away that
light traveling towards us
is just doesn't reach us anymore so
they're going to be potentially
creatures on this earth maybe
in a certain amount of time they're born
into existence and they look up at the
black sky and they see nothing and they
think
there's nothing so are we just getting
prepped for that with all this light
pollution
no look we can look at the stars and we
understand the universe exists because
we can see the light that has reached us
but if the universe expands to
if it keeps expanding eventually it'll
be too far away for us to even see
because the light will never reach us
all they'll have is our records and the
teachers will teach the records until
the records become racist and they're
not
going to teach them it'll it'll be fake
it'll be magic to them they'll be like
we know it doesn't exist because you can
look out there's nothing there it was a
bunch of
dreams and hallucinations of these
people but here's the thing if you can't
see the stars
you can't conceptualize the concept of
outer space and stars
so you'd have to take it on faith no but
the concept wouldn't exist
what if there was something where like
you know interdimensional elves would
randomly appear and then one day
you know a thousand years ago they all
died off so it would come off it'd come
out like
leprechauns don't exist yeah it would it
would be it would become a myth
right right you know way distant out
there there are these things called
stars and you know eventually would fade
into
and they would make movies about like
stars coming to earth and like
giving people magic powers because they
wouldn't understand what it actually was
yeah i think the universe is rubber
banding so
it's it is accelerating now and it's
getting bigger faster but it will
eventually slow back down and start to
come
back together and then pop again that's
called big crunch theory it was
disproven a long long time ago i think
there's a lot of those happening like
popcorning all over
so multiverse they initially we had
solid state theory
do you know solid state theories the
universe is and has always been
then we had eventually big bang the big
bang theory that
the universe is expanding and from that
we had a lot of people theorize
something called the big crunch
that if the energy is being pushed out
at a certain point could it
start coming back in a better way to
explain it is if gravity attracts
wouldn't at a certain point everything
condensed into singularities and then
all starts
moving back towards each other wasn't
stephen hawking that was disproven
wasn't he one of the ones that disproved
he didn't he
he thought everything was shrinking and
he like wrote a whole thesis on it
and then he's like now i'm gonna
disprove my own theory and he wrote a
whole thesis on how it's expanding
yeah so uh basically where we're at now
is that the universe is actually
accelerating faster and faster and
faster as if the ball is rolling down
the hill
at no point will the ball just stop and
then roll well if it goes down and then
goes back up
and then back down and back up you might
start to see it because gravity is
actually a pressure it's pushing it's
not being it's not a pulling force it's
a pushing force so
it's possible that things are being
expelled into a universe
that's actually trying to push them back
but they're still in a rate of
acceleration
and will eventually be pushed back
together so i guess it is still a
hypothesis
when you look it up they they just
basically say it's a hypothesis
that's good there's something called the
big balance propose that it keeps going
back and forth a big bang big crunch big
bang bang
that's interesting big bounces yeah big
bounce
um hey regarding what we were talking
about earlier i think the cia is giving
us disinformation
i think that's just rampant what the cia
does you think that they're giving it
just to distract us and keep us
like talking about aliens while they do
their dirty work yes and some of them
maybe are truly deluded and making crazy
theories or they did hear from a friend
something um i don't trust like hidden
sources well i know one of the sources
that i
red flagged me was the john brennan
yes yeah what happened in the article it
said john brennan says that we're stupid
to think or arrogant to think that we're
the only species
as soon as they quoted john brennan i'm
like uh john brennan is just dirty
swampy i love john brennan
me too yeah yeah you know i would love
to you know be like the best evening
ever
what bezos zuckerberg brennan you know
just
hanging barack obama company yeah yeah
just all these these
these these heroes that'd be awesome
bill gates in a sauna
so it's hot yeah you know actually
actually you know be really great what
in asana with brennan bill gates
zuckerberg bezos and alex jones
oh oh that might actually be fun
yeah you have to wear like a shield
though because you'd go off i'd
pay for that i'd like to be in this
sauna at this time well whatever this
conversation is begins
mm-hmm cold water i'd watch it on
pay-per-view
yes pay-per-view yeah yeah put a gopro
in there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you